[Music]
the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
all right welcome to the bonus show um
it's very difficult to keep up with
everything that's going on in a story
that
made some headlines yesterday but it
just you know with rudy giuliani farting
at the hearing there was no way that we
were going to have time for this story
on the regular show as you can imagine
pat
ivanka trump was i'm half serious when i
say that ivanka trump was deposed
this week as part of a lawsuit from
the washington dc attorney general which
says ivanka misused funds i'm sorry
which alleges
the misuse of funds from trump's 2017
inauguration
in which ivanka was involved and may
have knowledge
and she had a deposition the way
in which i mean listen there's actually
a bunch of different ways pat
in which those funds may have been
misused and they're only looking at some
of them because some others are really
difficult to prove
but as an ex like for example favors in
exchange for donating to the inaugural
fund that's
very difficult to prove but what they're
looking into
is that they i mean it's essentially
almost like a money laundering
where the inaugural committee
deliberately paid
above market prices for things
presumably because they were giving the
contracts to friends of theirs or to
others
instead of actually like shopping around
contracts
and this includes paying more than
market rate to the trump hotel
and a whole bunch of other stuff and
ivanka confirmed that she participated
in the deposition for five hours
it's i mean it's impos the number of
investigations and the number of
different ways in which this family
has at least potentially defrauded
donors the american people
taxpayers it's truly stunning yeah i
vaguely remember this scandal from four
years ago but i haven't thought about it
in a long time because yeah
so much has happened since then um and
it's it's funny how we're working on the
next inauguration like they're building
the scaffolding now at the capitol for
joe biden's inauguration and they're
still focused on this that happened uh
four years ago
goes to show that they'll probably the
trump team trump's associates trump
family members will have to
face a bunch of different lawsuits maybe
some criminal investigations too
in the years after they leave office
because none of this is going away
no and there were a lot of things that
prosecutors may have held up
for these four years because trump was
in office and you know you don't want to
uh
go after sitting president because it's
a bad look they're going to have to
start
facing a lot of those consequences i
think pretty soon and we're starting to
see that now yeah now by cut
the thing the thing is what we mean by
consequences i do think that this is
going to be a thorn in the trump
family's side
for a while will there be and that that
will be a consequence they will spend
money on legal defense and so on
will there really be consequences to
them as individuals
in terms of criminality or even fines i
i just very much doubt
it and maybe they'll have to pay some
settlements here and there that'll lose
them a few million dollars but they
stand to profit
so much off of trump's name at this
point because
you know the his ability to make money
has increased so much over these past
five years uh and once he's out of
office he'll be able to do it without
any sort of um
ethical violations that he would have to
worry about he's been doing it despite
those violations anyway but yeah
you know now he can have a full pass to
make all the money he wants
and it's funny how yesterday on the on
the regular show we talked about how um
trump is considering issuing blanket
pardons for his children
but ivanka wasn't one of those people oh
she wasn't oh i thought she was i
thought it was ivanka don and eric
oh and it was jared kushner also yeah
okay and tiffany trump wasn't tiffany
was not yeah oh okay
i was gonna say maybe uh yeah maybe
ivanka will need that preemptive party
maybe not for a case like this because i
don't think it's going to get criminal
or anything like that but
who knows what else they've done over
these past four years now there are
they're real questions about what
trump's actual net worth is and it's
like
it's not because i care how much of a
billionaire he is but it's about the
reality that a lot of trump's net worth
is tied up
in buildings and um the value of a
building that is not even
on the market is definitely something
that you know particularly with these
gigantic buildings
how much can you really get for the
building and you can fudge your net
worth dramatically what we do know is
trump has 400 million in
in loans coming due over the next few
years and it's not clear how much cash
trump actually has
trump now as a former as a soon to be
former president
at the drop of a hat he can make an
ungodly amount of money writing a book
former presidents get book deals and at
just
you know trump is not the type of guy to
read nor write a lot of trump's
followers are not the types of people to
read
at all but if trump writes a
quote writes a book in other words tells
stories to someone who writes it
a lot of his followers will buy that and
that would be a very quick way for trump
to make some cash in the next couple
years
and obama just came out with his book
right so well it's another book obama
has written several now well his memoir
on his years in office i wonder if trump
will try to get more money for his
memoir
or if that'll be like a competition for
him you know
trump's debt coming due once he leaves
office i don't i don't think he'll have
that much of an issue paying it
maybe he doesn't have the money now but
as you point out he'll have all these
business opportunities going forward he
can make speeches for
you know hundreds of thousands of
dollars per appearance imagine paying
the guy can barely put together a
sentence imagine paying him to speak but
people will
yeah and if you break it down it's
probably like a hundred dollars per word
at those speeches
but it's just an excuse to pay him off
and you know there are plenty of
supporters in the country who are
willing to give him money despite the
fact that he's supposedly a billionaire
they don't care if trump asks for money
they'll give it to him and it doesn't
really matter what the excuse is
hey um over the last couple years we've
had these anecdotal stories about
uh miniature horses on planes as support
animals
pigs peacocks and all sorts of different
animals
and there has been a major ruling by the
department of transportation that dogs
are the only animals defined as
service animals and therefore as far as
airlines are concerned
dogs are the only service animals that
are going to be
allowed and the transportation
department is defining a service animal
as a
dog individually trained
to do work or perform tasks for the
benefit of a person with a disability
uh emotional support animals are no
longer considered service animals
but the ruling requires airlines to
allow dogs that are psychiatric
service animals so this is a very
interesting thing you know i have
friends that work both for airlines and
for trains let me just put it that way
and
they've expressed that they see a lot of
playing very fast and loose
with service animals in general now
anytime i hear that i have a little bit
of a resistance to it where i'm like
this is like people criticizing those on
welfare
i i let's be a little careful let's make
sure you know let's see what's going on
um and there's these different grades
when it comes to service animals
there are actual service animals for
individuals with
with typically physical disabilities the
next grade would be
as is mentioned here a psychiatric
service animal which is not just an
emotional support dog
that a social worker for example or
psychologist can sign off on it would be
an actual
medical doctor psychiatrist who says
there's a psychiatric need here
and then you have this emotional support
characterization
which is very often legitimate but
because i know so many people who work
in mental health
there is a certificate mill where you
can there are many therapists you can
google this
you have one session with them you pay
them 150 bucks
you tell them why you need the am the
support animal and they write you
something and it's an emotional support
animal and
sometimes that is accepted in certain
situations i think at this point pat
there is no doubt that there are people
taking advantage of this
at the same time i'm always hesitant to
say take things away from people who
would need it
but it seems that there is some
consensus forming that
at least we can restrict this a little
bit in some cases
right so i'll give you an anecdotal
example here i have two friends who
both have registered emotional support
animals yeah the animals are dogs
and they don't actually need to have
these animals registered
as emotional support animals they just
want to get the dogs on the planes and
it's much more convenient and
they can get the dogs into places where
they otherwise couldn't and so you know
those are just two examples of my
friends
but if you scale that up there probably
are plenty of people who are
cheating the system here in a way and
they're maybe taking it away from people
who actually need
emotional support animals for legitimate
reasons so that is a concern
but i think ultimately i'm upset with
the rule change because i think this is
a way that people could stick it to the
man right
you know you bring your animal on the
plane with you it's nice you have the
company
i think even the people next to you
sitting on the plane are going to enjoy
seeing the dog there
yeah but there are also pictures of
people on the plane sitting next to like
there's a picture of two gigantic
huskies they're almost like wolf dogs
taking up first class seats and
taking up more than a single first class
c i i don't i think there's examples of
everything here
well we've heard about the emotional
support peacocks how cool would it be
if you're sitting on a plane and next to
you you have a person with a peacock how
could you
possibly complain about that right even
if you're upset for the few hours of the
flight that's a great story that you
have there so i think it's a win for
everyone uh i don't even really
understand how a peacock
i don't understand how a peacock even
has the sort of cognition level
that an animal would need to have to be
an emotional support animal but maybe i
don't understand enough about the
biology of the peacock
well maybe it's because those male
peacocks have those beautiful colors
yeah and the person who needs emotional
support can just take a look at the
peacock
and it makes them feel happy and if
that's good enough for them it's good
enough for me and i think they should be
able to move forward with this
and you know i'm against the department
of transportation's decision here i
think they need to relook this
you want you want what uh you want
horses on the plane right
i want horses i want cows every single
animal
yeah put a cow on listen what i have a
uh i have an emotional support hippo
actually
um no listen i mean with all these
things that the difficulty is
when you give an inch people take a mile
and so you have to do something because
it you know airplanes can't be barn
yards it just it can't be that way but
you don't want to restrict
people who are properly doing what they
need to do and i have i have friends who
are therapists who have signed off on
emotional support animals
i have friends with huge dogs who have
told me i got a therapist and
got them to sign off on my dog because i
don't want the dog going downstairs i
want it sitting down underneath my seat
and the way to do that is you say it's
an emotional support animal but it has
no training and it really means nothing
i see both sides of this it sounds like
you're a little bit more okay with the
rule change though
than i am i just want everything to go
on these planes i suppose what about
snakes on a plane
yep snakes yeah you can do that make a
movie out of it if you want to
uh just about any animal i would say so
this weekend we are going to have a real
party and i use that term very loosely
on saturday donald trump is holding a
rally which i will be covering live he
is going to be
i guess supporting the rep republican
candidates in the runoff although
it's not clear he's even telling people
to vote i mean on the on the one hand
there's these questions about whether
trump believes the election for the
senate runoffs will be trustworthy
and um there are now allies
of trump in georgia who are saying
uh listen we should boycott this
election
and of course if they do that
republicans
risk losing those two seats and thus
losing control of the senate
now as you know pat as a principal i
am in everything okay over there pat you
seem nervous yeah i heard a car backing
up i didn't know if i was picking up
a car came through pat's window while
we're talking um
on the one hand i want maximum voter
turnout i want everybody to vote i think
the more engagement we have the better
i know even ignorant people are allowed
to vote but listen this is a system we
have
more turnout i believe is better and
more turnout i believe
helps the more progressive candidate at
the same time
if you're telling me that republicans
are telling republicans not to vote
i'm not going to go out and tell
republicans to stay home but if
republicans are saying
it's rigged boycott the election and
that could help democrats take the
senate which could help
joe biden actually get major legislative
accomplishments done
have at it i'm not going to get in the
way right i think it would be unethical
for us to make the argument that people
shouldn't go out and vote because the
election's rigged anyway what's the
point they don't even
see a point in voting and we've been
arguing for years that we want people to
vote so now if i say
except here republicans should stay home
that's exactly what we we are against
but luckily we don't even have to make
that argument because they're making the
argument
republicans are saying this and it
logically follows right i mean they said
that the last election was rigged
you know you're still using the same
voting system you're still counting the
votes the same way why wouldn't this one
be
rigged by that exact same logic and i
wonder if people know better but they
just
have been brainwashed by trump or like
they're trying to fit these two
different ideas in their head about how
their vote is supposed to count but
trump should have won and
they don't know how to reconcile those
two things um and so
you know you don't need to have every
republican stay home too that's the
other point
the last uh georgia senate races came
down to pretty tight margins you know
just a few percentage points as most
elections do
and if you're able to you know if maybe
ten percent of republicans stay home
because they think there's no point in
voting that could be enough to that
could be the difference maybe
yeah yeah no i i agree with you and um i
did now
it it's all crazy like the georgia
election wasn't rigged and donald trump
really lost all that stuff but you are
getting to one
important thing which is the internal
logic is
sound that if the trump biden numbers
were fake
in november and the senate numbers were
fake in november
you would expect that the same things
would be happening in the runoff
that internally is coherent but that's
only if you buy into this thing at all
the same logic will apply for
fundraising too why should someone
donate money if the election's going to
be rigged
and that's of course going to be a
benefit for democrats they can use that
money to add spend
and hopefully push warnock and ossif to
victory
i still think it's an uphill battle
though like i don't know what you're uh
putting the percentages at at this point
but
i i would say like the chance of us
winning both seats or maybe about 30
percent
so i would put it low so basically i
think that
roughly i think let me even pull up a
calculator
i think that each each democrat has
about a 45
chance of winning their race
now simple probability analysis
uh would tell us that if each candidate
has a 45 percent chance of winning
the odds that they both win would be
0.45
0.5 which is a 20 chance so i think
there's a 20
chance that democrats get both seats i
think there's
a 45 chance that democrats get
one seat and i think there's a 35 chance
democrats get
neither seat yeah so it is an uphill
battle it's doable it's going to be a
great day if we do indeed pull it off
but um
i guess we should be prepared for the
worst it would be also kind of
unsettling if we got one seat and not
the other although it would push us one
step closer so that would be good as
well
i suppose because i'm a silver lining
kind of guy the silver lining
to both republicans winning would be
that it makes trump look even more
foolish
and it would show that the election
wasn't actually rigged that's actually
that's true yeah you can make that
statement about like everything else
that's going on there are plenty of
other things that disprove trump's
allegations and they don't care they
just move on to the next thing
no question no yeah you're applying
consistent logic
to this and there is no such consistent
logic
being applied by by republican voters
quite frankly
reminder tonight david pakman show chess
tournament
in partnership with international chess
master levi rosman
grand master benjamin feingold and
supporter of the david pakman show
and all around good guy will be playing
in the tournament
there may be some other very very
special guests as well
it's open to everybody this is just fun
it's
a break from politics go to
davidpakman.com
chess and join the
davidpakmanshowchest.com chess club
tonight within an hour so the
tournaments at eight eastern
starting at seven eastern you'll be able
to register for the tournament
okay um it's gonna be great time pat
will be playing
i will be playing for the first hour
it's a 90 minute tournament and
i guess the last half hour i will bow
out and i will do commentary
on the games of the leaders in the
tournament with levy rosman
so i think that's the plan i will
participate in just the first hour but
it wouldn't be fair
for me to compete to the end because i'm
oregon it wouldn't be
if the organizer i don't want to be
brian kemp in georgia right
i can't organize the tournament and
compete for the win so i'll play for an
hour
and then we'll see the top games and i'm
told you are going to be playing pat
i'll be playing so there's a chance that
i make it into the winner's bracket in
that last half hour and you might be
commenting on
my game sure because you don't know how
much i've improved over these last few
months since we last had a chess
tournament maybe i'm getting
to master level at this point you just
don't know it yet it's all certainly
conceivable so i invite everybody who
wants to play to play davidpakman.com
chess 90-minute tournament at 8pm
eastern time
davidpakman.com chess and then we'll see
everybody tomorrow
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]